en el vídeo pasado estudiamos una
economía bastante sencilla que solamente
vendía un bien o servicio
eso era manzanas solamente vendían
manzanas pero en este vídeo pensemos en
algo más general pensemos en una
economía más compleja digamos que en el
año 1 los economistas de un país
determinaron que el nivel de los precios
para ese año fue de 100 supongamos que
fue de 100 así que los economistas
esencialmente lo que hacen es determinar
su índice hicieron algunos cálculos y
ven que es de 100 y hacen eso para saber
los precios relativos a ese año tomando
a ese año como año base entonces digamos
que en el año 2 en el año 2 los
economistas
usando su índice ellos se dan cuenta se
dan cuenta que en el año 2 el nivel de
los precios ahora está en 110 esto esto
que quede claro que no es algo sencillo
de calcular a no no lo es lo sería si
sólo hubiera un bien o servicio en la
economía como fue el ejemplo anterior
manzanas primero en 50 centavos después
pasaron a 55 el hecho de que en el mundo
real haya muchos productos no
fácil calcular esto en los productos
bajan y suben de precio las calidades
cambian también hay productos en el año
1 que no existen en el año 2 viceversa
productos en el año 2 que no existían en
el año 1 pero por el bien de este vídeo
supongamos que los economistas pueden
decir eso que libre de los precios en el
año 1 fue de 100 y ahora está en 110
otra manera de pensarlo es decir que
todo se volvió 10 por ciento más caro y
yo sigo haciendo énfasis en esto no es
algo fácil de hacer de hecho no hay una
manera perfecta de hacerlo pero si
asumimos saber esta relación entonces la
pregunta es la siguiente cómo podríamos
averiguar una relación para calcular el
pib real y el pib nominal eso es
interesante ahora recuerda cada vez que
hablamos de pib real hablamos del pib
real aquí en el año 2 pib real sub 2
cuando hables de fibra les estás
hablando o te estás refiriendo al pib
con respecto a un año base así que aquí
estamos tomando el pib del año 2 en
términos en términos del año 1
y los siguientes pensar es cuáles fueron
los bienes y servicios producidos en esa
economía para el año 2 diremos bueno y
qué tal si qué pasaría si estuvieran en
los mismos precios que en el año 1 eso
de ahí nos daría el pib real una manera
de pensarlo es con esta razón la pondré
aquí la razón del pib nominal el pib
nominal del año 2000 nominal sub 2 / es
una proporción está proporción del pib
nominal dividido por el pib real el pib
real del año 2 del año 2 y ahora éste
pib real del año 2 es medido con dinero
del año 1 medido con dinero del año 1 y
bueno pues esto sería igual a la razón
de los precios entre el año 1 y el año 2
ahora muy bien vamos a pensar esto hay
que ser igual esto aquí es igual a
110-110 sobre sobre 100 esto es bastante
bastante divertido vamos vamos a
pensarlo un poco aquí que tenemos acá
esto ok esto de aquí son los mismos
bienes y servicios
real nos los están viviendo en términos
del año 1 mientras que el pib nominal
los mide en precios del año 2 así que si
todo se volvió 10% más caro el pib
nominal debe ser 10% más grande que el
pib real es lógico entonces estas
razones son equivalentes y como te digo
esto es divertido porque ahora podemos
manipular esto usando álgebra así que
por ejemplo nos estamos enfocando en
esto de aquí en esto de aquí nos estamos
enfocando entonces por ejemplo podemos
decir que el pib nominal lo voy a
escribir solamente nominal nominal el
pib nominal podemos multiplicar ambos
lados por el pib real esto nos da el pib
nominal el nominal es igual a 110 sobre
100 x el pib real el pib real ahora el
pib nominal está en términos del año 2
mientras que el pib nominal está medido
en términos del año 1 aquí está aquí lo
dijimos otra cosa también podríamos
dividir ambos lados de la ecuación por
esta razón 110 sobre 100
tendríamos obtendríamos nominal el pib
nominal del año 2 / 110% 10 sobre 100 en
amarillo 100 es igual al pib real es
igual al pib real del año 2 pib real sub
dos acá también de hecho voy a poner
mejor más más vale poner pib nominal
binominal sub 2 por escribirlo de esta
manera estás tomando tu pib nominal del
año 2 ya que hubo un incremento general
en el nivel de los precios a eso se le
llama inflación en los precios de hecho
aquí está aquí se ve ahora estamos
deflactando los precios para obtener el
pib real estamos dividiendo el nominal
por esta razón que indica el crecimiento
de los precios lo estamos dividiendo por
la razón entre los precios del año 2 y
desde el año 1 110 sobre 100 es 1.1 que
estamos haciendo estamos deflactando lo
puedes ver así estamos deflactando al
pib nominal para obtener el pib real del
año 2 estamos refrescando el pib nominal
del año 2 para obtener el pib real del
año 2 y no te olvides que esto de aquí
está medido en
del año 1 y justo por esa razón este
numerito este momento de aquí es
referido a ser un deflactor es un
deflactor este es nuestro deflactor del
pib ahora que se hace primero se toma un
año base aquí está este que en este caso
fue el año 1 nuestra base y puede ser
cualquier año pudo haber sido 1999 el
2005 el año que sea yo que sé el año que
tú quieras lo que sí es que tú deflactor
del pib será relativo a ese año a ese
año base tú deflactor te indica cuánto
cuestan las cosas en el año actual y tú
puedes ir también viceversa en un año en
un año anterior puedes ver que quizás
las cosas estaban más baratas o tal vez
no o tal vez en el año dos hubo
deflación quién sabe puede haber muchas
cosas ahora se le llama deflactor porque
a tu pin nominal no estás deflactando
siempre estarás dividiendo por algo
mayor a uno siempre será algo de la
forma mayor que si el dividió por cien
que esto año base y así obtendrás a tu
pib real